pretty cool stuff right there Barry Odom
and the new Rebel football staff been
out hitting that recruiting Trail hard
today they announced their Spring Class
18 players 14 High School Kids four
Junior College transfers Rebels signed
seven new players through the transfer
portal and then when you look at all
that's going on in this town this
weekend it's pretty amazing you got the
East-West Shrine game pro bowl a lot of
Big Time football here in this town and
UNLV can use all that as a selling point
for recruits but then you look at Vegas
and and you look at the opportunity
that's here you look at okay we've got
the Pro Bowl we've got the shrine game
and we've got the Super Bowl next year
Vegas is becoming the sports Mecca of
America that if you really take a step
back and look and think about the things
that we're going to accomplish together
in this program it's off the charts it's
really exciting all right finally
another week of